aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
travailler pour la commune apporter
quelque chose de nouveau à la commune et
mettre en valeur c'est qu'il ya mettre
en valeur de cette commune au macumba
il ya des gens qui ont été à droite à
gauche
aujourd'hui ces étiquettes cette
étiquette
elle est plus valable on a envie de
travailler vous une commune on oublie
tout ce qui est éthique est aujourd'hui
à trous de petite guerre entre voisins
entre justement de partis politiques qui
sont stériles et qui ne ramène rien qui
ne permet pas en fait à faire avance une
commune
donc c'est bon ça que le groupe
émergence 2020 m'a choisi comme tête de
liste pour transmettre ce message à
faire passer ce message
donc on essaiera de faire du mieux qu'on
peut avec des accompagnements avec des
colistiers qui ont vécu des élections
municipales qui savent ce que c'est donc
nous sommes encadrés
on fera le maximum nous sommes jeunes 7
ce sera compliqué mais on a envie de
faire de cette bataille